uh and uh issues other issues relating
to data in the sense of copyright
privacy watermarking you know bias and
so forth and the way I wanted to run it
this time a little bit different against
them yesterday is first of all give each
one of you
maybe exclude including you because
you've already spoken for an hour uh
three minutes to uh introduce yourself
and say something about like what keeps
you up at night uh in terms of L M's and
the subject of this panel so we'll start
with you please introduce yourself
hi
um Andi yeah I'm an assistant professor
in the computer science department at
Stanford University I work on natural
language processing and computational
social science in other words I care
about both large language models and
people and my research can be summarized
into a few Dimensions first is around
the fires and the fairness so we have
been talking about how amazing large
language model is the problem that I
care about is who gets represented in
the process there are a lot of factors
that are not a modeled into those big
models today such as around culture
social Norm vulnerable populations low
resource language dialects Etc so part
of my goal is how could we deeply
understand all those buyers
representation issues in those models
and then how could we mitigate those
issues so that we have more responsible
Technologies the second part is as those
models get him more and more impressive
this fact uh I guess
incapabilities exist we do see like
amazing applications of how how they can
actually affect society so in other
aspects we are also exploring how we can
leverage large language models to
empower individuals in very high
stakeholder scenarios such as in mental
health and in many other domains that's
three minutes thank you yeah thank you
I'm Jonathan Frankel I'm Chief scientist
at a a small startup called Mosaic ml
that I guess was just bought by a bigger
startup called databricks
um I train large language models and
other large generative models
for the public
um you know I release a lot of Open
Source models for my real business is
that I build the pipeline so everybody
can train their own custom models so if
you told me you wanted a custom chat GPT
3.5 on your data for your business case
that's basically what I do
um you know I'm coming at this from a
couple perspectives one is that I do
spend a lot of time in the lawn policy
world I technically once had the title
of Adjunct professor of law I don't know
anything about the law but I hung out
with a bunch of lawyers
um so this is something near and dear to
my heart the other is that I really
don't want to get sued
um I have to build these models very
frequently and I don't want to end up
like my friends at stability
um no offense if there's anyone from
stability in the room but I really don't
want to end up like you so it's
something that you know
I think a lot about not just what does
the law say but what will the law look
like in a couple of years and not just
what will the law look like but what
could it look like there's getting sued
and winning but there's also getting
sued and that's not fun even if you
eventually win
um the other thing just since Shafi
mentioned it I don't know why everybody
thinks the sky is falling and that we're
running out of data I don't know where
people get that from
um I got plenty of data um and that's
just the public data every company seems
to have as much data internally as I get
from web scrapes so there's plenty of
data just because you can't go and
download it for free it doesn't mean
it's not there so I'm not really sure I
fully understand why everybody thinks
the sky is falling on that front
my name is dang song I'm a professor in
computer science here at ioc Berkeley
and also a co-director of campus-wise
Center a responsible decentralized
intelligence actually just a little uh
announcement for the people who are here
and everybody here is really interesting
I am so actually on August 27th as about
a week and a half we'll actually have an
assignment on Berkeley campus and the
future of decentralization AI and
Computing and chefy actually will be
giving a keynote there so for people
here who are interested you can go to
the IDI website to
um to learn more details idi.brucky.edu
so my work is actually at in the
intersection of AI machine learning
security and also decentralization
um so
yes so of course it's a really exciting
time uh so so first um uh I'm really
concerned about the responsible AI so um
so essentially as a technology uh you
know advance so fast then there at the
same time there are lots of challenges
so recently uh we actually did a
comprehensive evaluation for these LMS
in terms of the various different
aspects for trustworthiness you can also
learn details um by going to decoding
trust that github.io and the evaluation
really Illustrated the huge challenges
open challenges in uh you know on one
hand these models are so on the other
hand
um they still you know like I'll have
all these issue toxicity uh you know
adversarial business uh and privacy
leakage and fairness bias and you know
really broad range so the question is on
one hand as a technology improves
naturally we have the tendencies that we
want to use these models but on the
other hand then how do we ensure that
these models actually when they're used
they don't cause more harm and another
thing that I'm really concerned about is
especially with this generative AI
um now of course you know all the ad
agencies and so everybody's utilizing
these Technologies so in the future
there will be these really targeted
personalized uh these AI generators
these contents that can Target
individuals to manipulate individuals uh
you know like perceptions and and so on
so on the other hand we don't have good
Technologies to really protect
individuals I think this attention-based
economy can just get you know much uh
much more challenging given the
yeah hi I'm Scott Aaronson I'm a
theoretical computer scientist at UT
Austin I'm on leave for two years now to
work at openai on uh foundations of AI
safety and one of the main things that's
been keeping me up at night has been the
problem of how do we make the outputs of
AI models uh identifiable as such for
example via cryptographic watermarking
uh and this is because you know I needed
a problem you know that was a sort of an
actual you know social problem or misuse
caused by uh language models for example
uh right now uh but also one where uh
you know the the there could be amenable
to a technical solution and where you
know theoretical computer science in
particular would have something to say
you know and there's not a whole lot in
the intersection of those requirements
but you know the problem of how to
Watermark is one of them I think that
we've made some progress on it and now
there's a you know there's the challenge
of getting the different AI companies to
coordinate on a solution uh if anyone is
interested I'll be giving a talk about
it uh tomorrow afternoon
um now you know regarding cop the a
copyright in particular I mean we all
just heard what an actual expert sounds
like uh no one would you know mistake me
for that although you know I might uh
tip off the legal people at open AI that
you know there are some very uh uh you
know plausible lines of defense that we
just heard in Professor samuelson's
talked that you know they might want to
take you know maybe with you know fair
use you know
um
but uh um you know what what one one
thought that I just had with listening
to to her talk was you know we've been
talking for several days about you know
this sort of just academic debate about
uh our language models you know just
stochastic parrots or are they really
creative and it occurs to me that this
is like a case where this act
how we feel about this actually matters
in practice because if you think of a
language model as just a stochastic
parrot right then you might say well you
know it's parroting all of this
copyrighted work and it's you know
supplanting the market for it and it's
doing it without permission that seems
very unfair on the other hand if you
think of it as just you know an
artificial version of of a human brain
then you would say well you know I'm
allowed to go to the library and read
all of the books right I'm allowed to
you know come up with my own original
works you know inspired by what I read
right and so so I think that that the
the academic debate actually these sort
of ties into the legal one in some ways
but but yeah it doesn't have any legal
status right like of course right so one
thing actually that I I think is really
important and what you've said
um what you just said
um is worth commenting on which is
metaphors make a huge difference
in the law okay especially when you
don't understand what some what what's
what's going on
um so uh years ago
um there was a big lawsuit between Apple
and Microsoft
um and
um also between Lotus and uh Lotus and
Borland
um remember those
um and uh metaphors won those cases uh
what is uh what I'm what I mean by this
when the trial judge said
that the graphical user interface uh
issues uh before the court
um looked like an automobile dashboard
the case was over
because automobile dashboards are not
protectable by copyright law so the
metaphor of that now now Apple had had
these really creative people designing
all this choreography and blah blah blah
they tried to you know make it seem like
you know this is just like cartoons and
you know and creative kind of stuff
that's interaction and blah blah blah
Court said look like a dashboard to me
okay
um and in the Lotus view Borland case
um it was the analogy to the buttons of
a VCR okay so the this issue that you
just raised about you know is it a
stochastic parrot
leads in the direction of infringement
and the
um the other metaphor leads to oh it's
independent creation
um so metaphors are something that
um you know you guys play around with
those and you use words that sometimes
lawyers basically say you shouldn't use
that word okay so memorization for
example right you guys you guys have a
word for that okay memorization sounds
like copyright infringement to a
copyright lawyer okay
um and
um uh at the at the icml conference
um uh you know we were hearing about how
important pre-training is it's like
pre-training doesn't is not the right
word okay it's not the right phrase if
in fact that's the really important part
of the development process
um and so pre-training kind of sounds
like you know like um just assembling
the the the little stuff that you do
before you do the real stuff
um and and so metaphors are really super
important and so here are the lawyers
basically don't use that word
memorization
um because it has all this ramifications
anyway but going Beyond metaphors so the
question really here is what do we
believe and I think is a community that
word is not we're not clear on this are
these models way understanding and
coming up with new uh understandings or
as you say it's a brain that has you
know insights or are we just we regret
how do you say it in English I think
we're agitating
or parody and I think that's a technical
question I don't know if anybody wants
to I mean I mean I I feel like I feel
like in cases where you can point to a
specific work that was substantially
infringed by the output of a language
model or you know they're basically the
same or like if you have a copyrighted
book and if you can ask the language
model to sort of Passage by passage to
reproduce that book for you right then
maybe you know the copyright holder of
that book ought to have some recourse
right but if it's just generalized you
know this data got fed into the mall
right then it then that feels more to me
like well you know when I read a book
you know it has some effect on the
synaptic weights in my brain right some
some diffuse effect that of course
influences everything that I do from
that point forward but maybe that's just
covered by fair use and then that that
feels more to me like at that point you
want to change the law right if you if
if you want you know there'd be you know
if you want that to be illegal then you
want a new and different copyright
regime I don't know
yeah I I think to some extent it's a
little bit unknowable
I think if we're predicating anything we
do in our understanding of what's
Happening inside these models we're
gonna have a very bad time
um maybe this is me being kind of a an
extreme empiricist here but you know we
don't understand whether humans are just
stochastic parrots at the end of the day
as well and a lot of my looking at gbt4
has made me feel like wow if we think
this is human level then maybe we as
humans are not as smart as we think
um so you know they're then you get
philosophical very quickly and you get
to the question of you know what is an
idea and what is originality and all
that good stuff that I leave to the
lawyers so I think the real question for
me is going to be if we do treat this as
strictly a black box if it is just
looking at inputs and outputs and I
think what Scott said makes a lot of
sense on that front
I don't know if we're ever going to get
to the level of understanding where we
can draw a line between is it a
stochastic parrot and is it actually
doing something more sophisticated
um
what the development said I think one
thing also is maybe when you to change
the questions that we're asking so so
obviously as we can see it's not just
regurgitating it can create new things
and also the question of understanding
even like we don't even have a good
definition of what it means for human
understanding I think the whole
Community has thought about this
question for a really long time and we
still don't have an answer for that I
think what we are seeing is as we know
we are creating this alien technology
um that somehow right it has these new
capabilities on one hand these new
capabilities can help it to solve
because a lot of problems that's hard
for humans but on the other hand we know
that also it can make really sitting
mistakes so I think what we need to what
we are recognizing is that this is a
complete new type of technology that we
have and we have no understanding and
not much understanding of and we have
never seen anything like this before and
it can continue to improve and they can
improve fashion fashion can improve by
itself in the future as well so in some
sense I feel we need to start asking a
different question is what this
technology can really do where it can
lead to and what are the pickfalls and
what's what's its limitations and now
just trying to do the analogy with
humans
yeah I have three cures to share uh
first is understanding and then uh
comparison and also uh evaluation so I
think understanding is not a binary
construct we all agree it's a spectrum
even for humans it's really hard to see
whether I really understand a skill
let's say co-reference resolution or uh
mathematical reasoning right it's really
hard to Define it and I think when you
make make the comparison or make the
story around the GPT for whether it's a
really be smart or not smart I think
it's really important to keep in mind
who or which human group we are
referring to I think lgd4 is probably
much better than me in solving those
puzzles right and then but uh who is the
group we are going to use in the
comparison here in terms of writing
poems in terms of solving mathematical
issues etc etc so that's like the
reference point when we think about it
when we mention uh understanding here
the other thing is that whether they
really understand how X I think so far
it always comes to how we evaluate them
and evaluation is always like we use
what we know to evaluate the models so
if you look at our evaluation procedure
we have benchmarks benchmarks are
produced by humans so we are evaluating
models using the knowledge we know maybe
they are producing a lot of creative
original content we just happen to find
a systematic way to justify it the space
is huge I don't think we have to do
enough have done enough to kind of
explore what creation water originality
or novelty means and then if we have
ways or devices to achieve that then
maybe whether they are stochastic
Pirates will be answered to some extent
so I want to follow up on something the
dancing uh about the wrong thing is to
compare these systems to to people and
we should have sort of different uh it's
not like a person that we're trying to
match uh and talk about scale so I guess
you talked about fair use and that I
guess it was designed in a different
area to uh talk about you know things
with a much smaller scale and what what
do you think are the principles that we
should follow when we update the policy
to an Era where scale is so much larger
so much more data and so forth
um
so I'm not sure
um uh in in two or three minutes I can
uh do something uh say something
particularly helpful uh here um and this
sounds like something that would be
better to have a longer conversation
about
um I do think that
um that Norms are gonna are gonna be
evolving in this space and that
um the kind of policies should evolve
with the norms and there should be
conversation about what those Norms
ought to be
um and right now a lot of the way that
the Norms are
kind of getting created is through
licenses that that people basically slap
on uh on data
um and
um I had an interesting conversation
with Joey Gonzalez um about hey what
kind of license should we slap on the
data that we're uh that we're using to
make um uh for training and
um you know people are just slapping
licenses on it and they don't know what
really the license ought to be and so
this is another fruitful place where
lawyers and technologists might actually
work together
um to uh to come up with Norms
um uh one of the things that makes open
source
work is that you can claim copyright in
the code that you write and then the
copyright gives you a hook to then be
able to license it either open or in a
proprietary way but if you do it with
the open then you can enforce that
openness
if we're talking about data and a
compilation of data that that isn't
creatively selected and arranged in the
way that copyright considers to be right
if you're just throwing out bad data
that's not creative in the way that
copyright care is about so so a lot of
the data collections are probably not
protectable by copyright law therefore
you don't have any intellectual property
right in it and if you don't have any
intellectual property right in it how
can you possibly use there's no hook for
a license and so if you respect the
license it's because it reflects an Norm
that you're willing to follow as opposed
to it's something that's legally
enforceable so a lot of open licenses
really are about
Norms about sharing right I I don't want
this particular kind of use of my thing
I'm making that a condition of the your
basically agreeing to is openness but
um you know the licenses may not in fact
be reinforceable
I I'm curious to kind of maybe rephrase
shafi's question a little bit I think
one of the interesting things with any
technology is that it makes it much
easier to do something that would have
taken a lot of work and had a lot of
cost in the past
you know in this case maybe it makes it
easy to infringe at Mass scales in ways
that might have been more difficult in
decades fast and I know in my very
minimal time hanging out with lawyers
that there is a big question of kind of
what is easy and what is hard where is
there friction where is there not and
there seem to be fault lines in
technology and how we you know think
about policy and regulation when that
level of friction changes substantially
or when something can be done in a
mechanized way that could not be done in
a mechanized way before I'm sorry to
make it be a stand-in for all of legal
scholarship Pam but I'm I'm curious if
there's any concept of that floating
around where you know infringement has
become much easier in some way and that
changes our calculus yeah it's really
the the example
um historically is photocopying right
the there was a long time agreement that
if a scholar or someone copied something
by hand
that that wasn't an infringement
and then early development of
um uh reprography Technologies
um made kind of icky copies and nobody
really complained about that there was a
what was called a gentleman's agreement
between some scholarly people and some
Publishers that basically making copies
in under that technology was okay then
Xerox comes along and all of a sudden
you have really high quality photocopies
and Publishers went nuts and there was a
whole bunch of lawsuits and stuff in
Congress and bottom line was because it
was it was higher quality because it
made it so much easier it had to be
infringement and therefore that it had
to be licensed and so that's an example
where something went from being really
hard to do to really easy to do and the
law eventually at least for commercial
copying and for at least course packs
remember course packs
um uh course packs are something where
um that had to be licensed that was an
easy way to make a new compilation
um uh that would displace the books that
the Publishers were selling and
Publishers said hey we should get some
money so the permissions Market
basically developed to address this so
that's a that's a historical example do
you think that diffusion models for
example are generative image models
represent enough of a change in the
difficulty of potentially infringing
that we may have to look at it
differently
but it's necessarily illegal so
um I I really I I don't want to say that
the efficiency uh and the sort of ease
and the speed
necessarily makes uh makes something
more illegal
um but but it is the case that there are
going to be people making those
arguments and that's why that's why
we're having this conversation because
this is not an easy problem to try to
solve I want to Pivot through another
question and then if we're going to open
to the audience in about five minutes so
there's a big connection between
copyright issues and privacy and in
particular I guess uh there's a lot of
methods for differential privacy
specifically out there uh to achieve
something that seems very related to
copyright so the measure is that whether
you participated or not participate in a
data set
um distinguishable in some sense uh of
course we know I think a lot of people
here know that all the differential
privacy methods introduce also error
lack of accuracy
and so forth so any thoughts about the
fundamental differences between
copyright and privacy and or what's
missing in my comparison uh anything to
say about it from any of you
um I've thought a bit about this so I
mean I I feel like differential privacy
as it stands is probably not you know
applicable to large language models
because you know it it's about you know
calculating you know statistical
averages right or you know statistical
information about a large population
where you know you don't want to be able
to infer things from from that about
individuals right but uh uh with large
language models it's as if we have you
know the sort of exponentially large
space of possible texts you know that
could have been written right and that's
very very sparsely populated by actual
texts uh and and and you know when you
see them like like of course it's going
to influence you know your output in a
way that could violate the guarantees of
differential privacy but having said
that I think there are creative ways of
dealing with this so um um Boaz Barack
and and others have a uh uh have had an
exciting idea recently which is that you
basically divide your training day you
randomly divide your training data into
two halves right and you train a
separate model you know on on each half
and then uh you know whenever you get a
prompt you see whether the uh the the
logits you know so like the probability
is the same you know according to both
of these models right and you you
produce an output you know only in cases
where it's where where both both of
these models trained on disjoint sets of
data would have given you comparable
proper probabilities and then you have a
defense against anyone one who says will
this relied essentially on my
copyrighted work which well you know no
well this other model that wasn't
trained on the work at all you know had
an output with a similar you know would
have would have had an output with a
similar probability so um
yeah I think you know that you know that
that's been prototyped a little bit and
maybe something like that would
eventually be a solution so I think you
wanted to go next and then you know yeah
uh
first I
I second just got on this I think a
differential privacy is really hard to
be applied to large language models and
especially giving that a lot of the data
we are dealing with are kind of
unstructured so it's really hard even to
kind of identify what is sensitive data
like assessment numbers are easy to
specify but there are a lot of other
type of information like maybe someone's
religions or maybe someone's hobbies
that they don't want others to know and
this kind of also
um introduce another kind of thing that
we always ignore I think therefore
um everyday users or other people the
constant whether I want to give away my
data is kind of unclear in most cases
when we talk about pre-training coppers
I think the artists or Scholars may have
a louder voice in terms of defining
whether my data is represented there but
like for majority silent I think it's
really harder to sort of tease out as a
constant issue here another thing
happening here I think is also about is
really unclear what the data has been
used today it's really hard to track
what type of data get involved or
transformed in this process it's not
only just like in the pre-training stage
or in output stage what happened so I
think this kind of uh tracking or
observation ability of hot data flow
into the process is another thing if we
want to do something like privacy
preserving we need to pay attention to
and in terms of methods I think that we
need to be more creative like in
addition to what the scholar mentioned I
think something more like from an attack
a defense perspective like how could we
treat models more at the uh Downstream
side not at the portraying stage in
terms of how we can guarantee privacy is
some quick thought
okay yeah um I'd like to clarify a few
things so first I think we are
discussing several different uh
um different problems or concepts so so
one question is whether you can apply a
DP to to around large language models
and there's a separate question whether
this actually helps with addressing
copyright problems I think we need to
differentiate this too so first of all
of course you can apply DP to to large
language models you can do DPA SGD and
you can apply the same to you know for
differentiate product training any of
these you know space right models
um and the goal for the go there so then
the question is what do you get there
and what's the difference to copyright
so the goal there is not to solve the
copyright problem so so our earlier work
we actually did one of the earliest work
in the space showing that one so the
memorization actually it was
particularly popularized by our our
paper earlier and showing that this
language models actually they do
actually remember a lot and also you can
have these very effective attacks that
can extract the sensitive information
out of the original training data
including student Security numbers and
credit card numbers and all these things
um so the people actually want the the
Privacy enhanced technology Awards run
up Awards actually this year and there
we actually had we proposed a measure
actually and to particularly measure the
degree of memorization so that's
actually a metric that you can measure
and evaluate and then later on the
follow-up work we did also
extend us to even large large language
models and so on so so there we actually
show that if you train differential
private language models it actually can
help address these issues in solving
this type of problem in you know
protecting these extremely rare
sensitive data in the in the training
data set but however as Chef mentioned
so this technique is difficult to scale
to really large language models and also
gets more expensive and in general
actually in practice people don't try
but I think so first of all my work is
needed there and I think we can
definitely try more
um and to develop more effective methods
there but separately that problem that
that technology doesn't really address
the copyright problem so the copyright
problem also as what was gonna mentioned
you divide the students into into two
but actually the copyright material can
be embedded in the Trinity data for many
many times that's you know like we
actually know this when you crowd the
Internet it's there a lot so this type
of techniques actually doesn't address
those issues and and also
right right but then the cleaning
actually people have done a lot of work
in the space cleaning data itself it's a
nightmare it's a huge Challenge and so
so that's why this type of Technology
first of all the problem is different
than copyright problem and it doesn't
really help right now solving the
copyright problem so we do needs to
develop new methods so I'm going to open
to the crowd I want one last question
which is more of my interest okay so
you're now working for open AI for two
years you have your own company uh let's
say that there are these amazing
procedures that academics or the
research Community proposes that will
address privacy copyright and so forth
and let's say these companies say they
do it how do we actually verify that I
mean there's this basic trust which I
don't is misplaced in my opinion when
money is involved what anything to say
about that I'm gonna I'm gonna put Scott
on the spot here I open source all my
code and all my models so if you want to
check my data sets are available on S3
buckets and you can download them right
now what are you doing I'm I'm not I'm
not going to speak for open AI
verification could be a process yeah you
can probably can verify even though it's
internally done I mean I mean I mean
presumably if someone sues a company
then these things will come out in
Discovery right
I was thinking more about verification
it is yeah I mean it's not a I don't
think either of these are very
satisfying answers right now and I wish
I had a better way to do this
um there's it is so easy to hide things
in a model and so easy to put trap doors
and models that will pop out at weird
moments when you don't expect them or to
poison models in various ways
the verification would have to be
something more fundamentally
computational that you can verify every
step of the computation that I performed
to get to a model and you know there's
some really cool work on this that I've
seen coming from you know yoshavit's
been working on this for a while and has
some cool stuff at openai
um but I think it's still in its infancy
right now it kind of gets to broader
questions of just trusted Computing and
whether you know you can verify the
operations that were performed
especially when you're performing this
much computation
it just seems like a tall order to me to
be completely Frank and anything that
costs you a little bit of efficiency is
costing you tens of millions of dollars
and if it's a voluntary thing you know I
want to do what's right but if it costs
me that much money
is it really worth it it's a fair
question
for its governance yeah and also I think
the community can develop even though
it's a it may be a black spot a black
box process but there are various
methods we can develop to evaluate the
you know the final property of the
models and so on so for example they're
having uh great work done in the space
of auditing differential privacy for
these models uh and so on so certain
properties I think may be easier than
others to to verify so for example if
you impact a backdoor in the model like
there is no good method to do that by
the first time of these other properties
right I think they're interesting
great discussion and now I'm going to
let questions so I think a nonsense
first actually there's a
great talk an interesting panel
discussion so far I want to come back
this question of metaphors that you
raise as being really important and
sometimes it feels that
some of the US who don't understand the
law sometimes hear things that seems
like it's almost a religious Purity law
type of metaphor you know like oh is
this thing clean or unclean right and it
seems that
um like you know is it does it have the
but you think what you seem to be
describing is that's not the metaphor
that the law uses at all for thinking
about it
um and so uh did I catch that correctly
it was one question the second is
you mentioned this issue of like how
equations and the expressive content of
something versus the kind of idea or
this just you're describing something
this is the nature of the world I mean
what are you gonna do about it and
sharing that with other people kind of
from the respective of copyright law
uh how is code different than clothing
in this Regard in terms of functionality
and sort of you have to do something
this way
um because it seems like I heard that
clothes are not copyrighted
um
and code is also trying to do something
so is this something just been well
worked out or is this again a math
question of dueling metaphors
so
except for computer programs and
Architectural works
things where there's an intermixture of
expression and functionality they're
just not protectable by copyright law at
all
that Congress made a choice to extend
copyright to computer programs to extend
copyright to architectural works even no
there's an intermixture of expression
and functionality
and
so what happens instead of saying this
isn't protectable the way that clothing
isn't protectable
you say
um it's protectable but it has a
narrower scope of protection because all
the functional parts are not within of
copyright now what are the functional
things oh boy
people like to fight about that
um the Google versus historical case is
a good example where
um the Declarations
um uh that that Google used in the
Android platform from standpoint of of
uh of Oracle This is highly creative
expression right there were lots of
choices when the when Java was first
developed there are lots of different
choices that you could have made and uh
you know son made this we acquired Sun
those are
highly creative and hey Joshua block you
even said it's so artistic
well
um from the standpoint of the Court
it looks functional because it
facilitates interoperability
um and
cross-platform
um utilities and therefore is not within
the scope of copyright so the
um we fight about these things all the
time but again some part of what I've
tried to convey here today is that the
law is very backwardly right it's like I
have this little pile of things that
we've decided before
and I'm going to reach into that thing
and pull out the thing that's the
closest analogy
that I know about
it it's very hard for courts basically
to say this isn't a case of first
impression
and I'm just gonna make it up like what
is the right answer right I'm going to
do my best to approximate something that
balances the interest right
but that's why the metaphors in cases
involving
um technology in particular
um in a very very helpful um so software
is another subject that I have spent a
lot in my life on um and so I've been
reveling with this since 1983.
so Anil yeah so um I have a question
based on something that Scott said
earlier you had talked about how
you know when humans go into a library
or when we read books and then
eventually almost everything we do post
that ingestion of information is going
to be influenced by what we ingested and
llms are doing something similar so how
is it any different I was wondering like
unless I'm ingesting pirated editions of
information either I have paid for those
books or I've gone to libraries which
have somehow bought those books so the
producers of the content have been
compensated in some way
but and to me the question seems to be
that llms are at this point and the
training data has been acquired in ways
that are not compensating the producers
of that information and so
is that something we should be worried
about or is that how we should be
thinking it
um yes llms might be doing something
very similar to what humans are doing
but in one case you know there is some
way of compensating the producers of
information I don't think that's
necessarily true though
open AI page Shutterstock some Untold
amount of money to license the data
Shutterstock puts a large chunk of that
money into a fund to go back to the
content creator so I think it's you know
it varies on the application how much in
images for some reason people seem to
like to take care of the creators and
pay them and people are good about suing
in text we seem to take everything for
free there seems to be two different
cultures there depending on what kind of
model you create but there are certainly
a lot of places where openai and meta's
got a similar agreement with shutter
stuff and I think Google does as well
where actually the creators do get
compensated
yeah so I'm neither a lawyer nor a
business person right so but uh uh uh uh
speaking personally you know I would
like you know creators to get you know
compensated for how their work is being
used right but you know I think you know
there's another consideration that I uh
I think is very important that I hadn't
uh heard it yet so I want to throw it
out right that we we all want language
models to not hallucinate so much right
we all want language models to not be
spouting racist invective right or you
know to to to give you know sort of
sound and helpful information well you
know how do you how do you get that
right a central way is by training them
on high quality data rather than you
know random crap that you find on
internet forums right and you know where
is that high quality data well a lot of
it is locked up and you know copyrighted
books for example right and so in some
sense for purposes of AI safety like
that is the data that you want to be
training on right and so that's why I'm
I'm
fervently hopeful that you know a
solution can be found that you know get
gets Fair compensation but that also
allows that data to be used in training
yeah
so one thing actually that I didn't
emphasize but I think is important here
um is that
a lot of the data that this stuff has
been trained on
um was put voluntarily on the internet
okay and
web crawling is something that's been
happening for a really long time and
nobody's actually really except for that
field case nobody's basically said oh
that web Crawling by itself is copyright
infringement
um so there's got to be you know
um a balance here now uh you know the
the if there are these pirate sites
uh which have these high quality books
um and you train on those that's a place
where that's a little dicey
um but it doesn't seem to me that
um uh that if I'm a if I'm a graphic
artist and I put I put my work on the on
the open internet I know that web
callers actually make copies of it so uh
but I think what we're seeing is yeah I
put it up on the open internet but I
didn't expect this okay and that's part
of the sort of
concern there so but uh
if you could come up with a good
compensation scheme for uh for training
data
um that would really be a good thing
yeah I think to this I think
um also we talked about earlier one
difference we are seeing here is with
this new technology certain things
become much easier and so for example
here previously
um this copyright materials so if you
have some pirate sites that has
copyrighted material if the site is not
very popular if not many people go to
the site then in general
um the people don't care because the
impact is very small but here it doesn't
matter whether your site is popular or
not the the model by crowding the
internet will be able to get this
copyright material and then we'll be
able to treat it this is for the model
it doesn't actually matter it doesn't
care whether it crowded from a really
popular
parasites or an imperf and unpopular one
so I think that's going to be a big
challenge going forward as well is that
we don't even know right like as long as
you train model from crowd internet you
you don't know where these copyright
materials where the violations have
happened and I think that's going to be
a huge challenge I want to get in one
last thought I mean Pam I I feel like I
have to play Paul ohm for 30 seconds
it's my legal obligation
um I mean what you just mentioned sounds
a lot like a kind of contextual
Integrity to me that there was kind of
an unforeseeable purpose for using the
data the data is being used outside of
the context for which it was put online
we've been talking almost exclusively
about copyright law this entire time
because we have one of the world experts
with us I'm kind of curious if there are
other bodies of law we should be
thinking about invoking here as we try
to make sense of this and I have to
bring up privacy again as my legal
obligation so I'm curious to maybe
that's a good way to close with kind of
a broader looking View
copyright has a little bit of privacy in
it so there are certain kinds of private
things that you do that copyright just
doesn't reach
um but um and if you let's say have a
diary and you keep your diary and then
someone takes your diary in and exposes
it
um copyright can actually essentially
protect your privacy in that kind of way
but very often
um these bodies of law kind of live in
different places and
um you know and
this is not the first time that
um that people have tried to use the law
to stop certain kind of of web crawling
okay so there was a a time where there
were some lawsuits called uh trespass to
Chatham right the idea that computers
are basically personal property
um and companies own it and somebody
uses uh that Network and uses your
computers and therefore is trespassing
on your property
um and that was actually like a theory
that people kind of what went crazy for
and then and people said no that just
doesn't make any sense at all
um and then there was the Computer Fraud
and Abuse Act Right that that you were
kind of exceeding authorized uh use and
so the high Q case that was before the
ninth circuit
um recently
um was based on LinkedIn basically said
you are you're uh you're exceeding right
I gave you access as a user but um uh
the the the user terms of service uh
means that you can't scrape this uh the
site for data that you want and uh so
you exceeded authorized access and
therefore
um uh you are liable under this law and
the ninth circuit said no
um so you know whether there should be
some sort of Regulation whether it's the
copyright tool or some other tool for
when is web scraping sort of a fair use
or when is it sort of socially
beneficial and therefore good or whether
it should be like you know regulated
um can be done for this purpose but not
for that purpose
um uh maybe there needs to be a
conversation about
um what's it you know do we have the
right tool
yep uh for this and I uh that's a good
question so I think we're out of time I
just wanted to just another uh we're
talking about terms of service so I just
read that on August 3rd the New York
Times changed their terms of service to
say that specifically they allow they
disallow any software program including
but not limited to
um training or machine learning or AI
system to use their material
um that's a big one New York Times
speaking of
sources that we actually trust
um
violating a term of service isn't
necessarily
protection uh anything other than a
breach of contract and we also have
historical web scrapes before the terms
were changed right
okay thank you this was a tremendous
thank you very much
foreign